une visite aux artisans et commerçants
de montfort l'amaury pour faire un point
sur la situation actuelle mais aussi le
protocole sanitaire mis en place pour la
réouverture une réouverture dès le 19
mai qui se veut progressive
en tout 400 mètres carrés on est sur une
superficie
je veux dire qui est totale dans le
magasin et donc c'est au regard cu huy
mètres carrés par personne et qu'on
puisse derrière avoir pour le 9 juin une
deuxième étape et après le 30 juin
situations spécifiques pour les
restaurants l'ouverture se fera en
terrasse avec 50% de la capacité
ce sera le cas pour yann marteau le
restaurateur a hâte d'ouvrir pour
retrouver le lien social et les clients
la mairie nos amis va nous mettre à
disposition comme l'année dernière une
extension de caras pour nous faire deux
belles terrasses avec environ une
centaine de mètres carrés chacun pour
pouvoir profiter pleinement du retour à
la normale dans d'autres commerces
restent en colère comme frédéric selon
la bijoutière un an plus tard rien n'a
changé ne pouvant être présentes sur
place pour réceptionner les commandes
la commerçante n'a pas pu anticiper ses
livraisons pour la réouverture
quand on se fait livrer c'est pas juste
les bijoux et hop on les balance comme
ça dans une vitrine
il faut faire les tic tac il faut
pointer il faut regarder enfin il ya
tout un tas de choses à faire
donc là je me suis fait livrer en plus
chez moi puisque ici je ne peux pas et
puis ben voila quoi là je suis en train
de préparer mes vitrines pour la
réouverture et pour la fête des mères
la première étape de réouverture aura
lieu ce mercredi 19 mai